make sure you have a tutor who has the
imagination that where with all the
resourcefulness to keep the conversation
going hi there steve coffin here
today i want to talk about how to get
the most
out of your online language tutor
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the bell for
notifications and if you follow me on a
podcast service please leave a review
so
in an earlier video i said that i'm
going to work harder on my output i'm
going to
you know work deliberately with my
persian tutor
uh twice a week we're going to have
deliberate subjects of conversation i'm
going to prepare for them and we're
going to see how that goes over the next
three months i'm particularly looking at
how to effectively
use link and the content and link and
the functionality at link to integrate
that with working with an online tutor
so this got me to thinking about how to
get the most out of a tutor online tutor
remember there are more and more online
tutors there are online tutors for every
language you can find them at
sites like italki or verbling you can
find them independent online tutors
there are lots of them so it's becoming
if not the mainstream compared to say
language schools more and more common as
a way of learning a language so how do
we benefit the most obviously
we want an online tutor primarily to
have someone to speak to
remember that
and possibly to explain the grammar but
to me that's not so important i can find
lots of explanations of grammar i don't
need the teacher to
walk me through the grammar
i'm also somewhat skeptical skeptical as
to how much benefit there is in
corrections it can help but it's not
necessary we do need the tutor for
speaking because eventually to speak
well you have to speak a lot
but
i mean unless you get
five hours a day with a tutor or even
three hours a day with the tutor every
day
which can get quite expensive you know
in fact you have to have a strategy
where you're mixing the tutor in with
your other activities in order to come
up with something that is cost efficient
and time efficient
now
i always get back this idea that to
speak well you have to speak a lot
obviously if you're in the country if
you have friends if you go out with
friends or you're working in an office
where everybody speaks the targeted
language that's an ideal scenario and
you're going to learn to speak
more quickly and this was my situation
in japan
where i did a lot of speaking in
japanese but i still did a lot of input
okay and so i think the secret in terms
of working with a tutor is to mix in the
input with the hours that you spend with
the tutor
and quickly some thoughts on on what i
expect of a tutor i expect the tutor to
lead the conversation i don't wall and i
have had tutors where if there's a lull
in the conversation my tutor most often
i'm female she's waiting for me to say
something i struggle to speak the
language i'm not going to say anything
the tutor has to keep the conversation
going so that's number one make sure you
have a tutor who has the imagination the
wherewithal the resourcefulness to keep
the conversation going when there's a
love love she comes up with a new
subject a new question something to keep
the conversation going so i think that's
number one number two make sure you have
a tutor who is encouraging
uh i have had tutors who make a face
when i make a mistake that's not very
good
you have to want to get together with
your tutor you want to feel encouraged
when you interact with your tutor
even if you haven't improved that much
if the tutor tells you you have improved
that's encouraging so you want to make
sure you have a tutor who encourages you
and you enjoy being with that tutor very
very important
another thing is i always insist that my
tutor
gives me a report with
10 or 15 words or phrases that i
struggled with and ideally that and they
put this in say a word document
and ideally and without any english you
know just the target language and then
they record this so that then creates a
lesson for me and link a lesson that i
can go back to six months later
all of these conversation reports become
part of a course which i can go back to
regularly and review the words that were
important to me at a certain stage which
i wanted to use and maybe didn't use
correctly
another thing that we're now starting to
do
with my tutor twice a week
which is you know economical because
twice a week that's
you know it costs money per hour to be
with a tutor
but
she has me focused on specific topics so
we are staying with economics i wanted
to move to another subject and she said
no we want to stay with economics we're
going to stay with one subject for a
while so that you get used to that
vocabulary and she then sends me links
to
articles in persian
where i come across this kind of
vocabulary and so i become familiar with
it so here again
uh she is kind of directing me and
keeping me focused
from my side
because i have
two sessions a week with her
i am motivated to improve
uh
most of my learning at link is is by
myself okay so i i'm motivated but when
i know that i'm going to be discussing
economics again for the third time in a
row
with my tutor i want to do better than
the last time so that is quite
motivating so the tutor not only is an
opportunity for me to to try to use what
i've been
you know inputting into my brain but i'm
also motivated i want
to do better
and if i'm lucky she'll tell me i did
better even if it isn't true but all of
that contributes to keeping me going
sending me back with more enthusiasm to
my input activities now
obviously in the file on that final
analysis to be a you know very
proficient speaker of persian let's say
i would i would have to spend a lot of
time speaking with
iranians in in persian and farsi
but
in this way that i work with you with my
tutor i'm building up my potential my
capability and i notice now that i
understand more than i did before and if
i understand more i will eventually be
able to
speak better i won't be able to remember
all the words but i will gradually be
able to speak better and i have had this
experience in preparation for a trip to
the czech republic
romania greece i always step up my
interaction with my tutors to two or
three times a week before going over
there and in fact
i sometimes try to arrange for tutors
as i did again with ukrainian
interaction with people while i'm over
there because it's sometimes difficult
to
interact meaningfully with the locals
but i in any case you have to prepare
for it and that's why i think depending
on your goals it's worthwhile having a
deliberate strategy in how you want to
work with your online tutor because it's
a tremendous opportunity that we have
today which didn't exist 20 years ago to
find people
from the country where the language is
spoken
people who have different personalities
so you can have more than one tutor
and all of that helps keep your
you know largely in my case input-based
language learning moving forward so just
some suggestions on how to work with the
tutor and i'll leave you with a couple
of videos i did on a similar subject
a while back just to see if my views
have changed
thank you for listening bye for now